nobody told me how big a man is had
closer friendships with random women I
met in the bathroom before I
transitioned at clubs because of how
open women are then I've had in my 8
years of transition and then you
transition and you're just a guy walking
down the street that people cross the
street so that they're not near you and
friendships are so much harder to build
that's the hard thing about being a guy
is men are just confused because they're
told one thing by society and how to
treat women and what women want they're
told that women want emotionally
available men but it's just not true
women want somebody strong that they can
look up to they they don't want you know
guys that are crying on Tik Tok